hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine motiv torte und zwar
in form eines 1 1 -erfolg und zwar zum
aktuellen kinostart von burg
schreckenstein das ist der film zu der
buchreihe von oliver heißen kampf und
zwar geht es darum dass der elfjährige
stefan aufs internat soll
und es trifft natürlich ziemlich hart
denn wer möchte schon auf internet gehen
und dort lernt er dann die ganzen jungs
kennen und wird zum echten
schreckenstein im film geht von bisschen
um den typischen geschlechterkampf
zwischen jungs und mädels und wir
schauen uns jetzt einfach mal ganz klipp
den trailer dazu an
kommst auf eine internet ein internet
sondern internet
es ist eine burg ganz alt richtig
abenteuerlich
sie ist es zuhause stefan herzlich
willkommen auf der meta ist kein
schrecken steiner beim hilfe meiner zu
werden
bist du bereit in mara schritt die
stellen sollten rose person ein streich
spielen sind die mädchen aus dem mit der
naht unten um sie vor allem behaupten
niederzier city schloss rotenfels gehört
die nacht mit euch sein
wer was tun
die sind zu weit gegangen
ist es hier nicht in den letzten zwei
jahrhunderten
das ist eine rhetorische frage
wahrscheinlich etwas speziell weibliches
keine de mission
wenn es keine mädchen können sie mir
fast leid tun
aber es sind mädchen was genommen
und wie fand student filmtrailer
ich fand es auch nicht die hatten
ketchup mittel schon gucken wir auf
jeden fall an oder ja also falls ihr den
film auch anschauen wollt wie gesagt ab
dem 20 oktober in den kinos und am ende
dieses videos gibt's noch ein kleines
gewinnspiel und jetzt würde ich sagen
kümmern wir uns um die torte und fangen
einfach mal an mit dem grundgerüst der
burg
ich habe hier schon mal was vorbereitet
und zwar bis hier einen kick box deshalb
25 x 13 cm größe und ich habe hier
einmal den saftigen schokokuchen
gebacken ein mal eckig und einem mini
passion in einem zwölf zentimeter back
ring und die werde ich jetzt erwartungen
back ring lösen
die habe ich heute morgen vorbereitet
das heißt sie sind schon richtig gut
abgekühlt
den kuchen nämlich jetzt mit einem paten
retter hoch man kann jetzt erstmal die
folie und es fragt mich weg und jetzt
werde ich erst mal ein paar rechtecke
zurechtschneiden und zwar mit 20 x 18 cm
größe etwa damit ihr einfach unten diese
diesen eckigen teil der burg ab und
obendrüber kommt ihr an der runde teil
habe ich die teile hier zurecht
geschnitten und drei platten
übereinander gestellt und das hat jetzt
den maßen jetzt ein bisschen kleiner
gemacht 15
19 da habe ich einfach nur etwas
kleinere burg und dem kreis hier werde
jetzt auch ein bisschen zurecht
schneiden zu einem 10 cm kreis geht mit
einem ausstecher oder zum beispiel
mitten im teller oder minder tasse jetzt
kann ich schon das skateboard nehmen und
mit etwas creme einstreichen habe ich
jetzt eine französische schokoladen
buttercreme das rezept auch bereits auf
dem blog und dies wirklich sehr lecker
und schmeckt auch nicht so sehr nach
futter sondern eher nach schokolade
jetzt wird die torte mit der creme
gefüllt und gestapelt
kommt da oben noch extrem drauf und da
kommt jetzt auch gleich dieser runde
teil drauf und bevor ich jetzt hier
weiterarbeiten stelle ich den kuchen
jetzt erstmal in den kühlschrank
jetzt ist die torte durch gekühlt ich
habe hier oben übrigens noch die reste
noch mal rund ausgestochen und
draufgesetzt und habe jetzt die
restliche buttercreme mit etwas
schwarzer lebensmittel verpasste
eingefärbt das ist einfach ein bisschen
aus wie mörtel die torte wird jetzt
einmal komplett damit eingestrichen und
dann bitte noch mal kühl gestellt
jetzt bereite ich ein bisschen
dekoration vor und zwar hab ich jetzt
hier schon mal das logo von buch
schreckenstein ausgedruckt und es ist
ein ziemlich kompliziertes nicht aber
ziemlich volles logos sind sehr viele
einzelne teile mit drauf und ich möchte
es später aufhängen
deswegen habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
weiße blüten passte bereits weiß
geknetet und rollte jetzt ganz schön aus
und hier habe ich eine kleine vorlage
gemacht und zwar ist sie etwas größer
als das logo selbst und es wird jetzt
eben diese fahne
die schneidet es doppeltes erst einmal
so dann klappt das papier um und schneit
so dass sie später über den stab legen
kann
jetzt gebe ich den spieß mit hilfe von
etwas essbarem hinein
die torte sitzt ein bisschen durch
gehört und ich koche eben nebenher
gradmesser für ella
deswegen ist auch gerade wieder
ungeduldig hat hunger jetzt werde ich
hier am rand so ein bisschen musik
schneiden also die ecken einlassen
geht's
und für die ecken nehme ich jetzt ein
paar schokoriegel
ich habe jetzt fix aber ihr könnt auch
gerne andere nehmen zwar kommen die hier
so dran
natürlich mit buttercreme und es gibt am
spätern richtig toller effekt mit
streiche ich nochmal die torte mit der
butter zum 1
und danach werden wir schon die von land
dekoration herstellen
jetzt sind die steilen transfair mich
etwas schwarzem und weißem fondant okay
dass die letzte auswahl hin zu schwarzen
hinten denkt geknetet habt und den werde
ich jetzt die zweite zu vermischen
dann entsteht grauer von dann und dabei
vertrete ich ihnen jetzt nicht komplett
denn ich möchte dass eine kleine marmor
optik erhalten bleibt also immer wieder
so ein bisschen zwirbeln mit auf den ca
und immer weiter und dann können wir
gleich einen schönen man häufig
jetzt könnte es entweder so machen dass
ihr diesen fordern jetzt ausrollt etwa
fünf millimeter dick und dann kleine
steine schneidet oder macht wie ich und
zwar nehme ich jetzt etwas becker stärke
und form jetzt lauter kleine
unregelmäßige steine und die drücke ich
jetzt so ein bisschen flach und da mache
ich jetzt große und kleine und die
werden dann angeklebt
die einzelnen steine kann ich jetzt auf
die buttercreme kleben und wir jetzt ein
bisschen butter kleben dann nach außen
dringt es gar nicht schlimm denn das
sieht dann aus wie ein bisschen wird und
die vorderseite ist die einzige seite
ruhig was beachten muss und zwar muss
ich mir da die mitte markieren denn da
kommt nämlich noch einen tür mit rein
und die stelle lasse ich jetzt erstmal
frei
die burg ist jetzt mag grob mit den
steinen belegt hier vorne habe ich immer
die großen steine und hier in den ecken
immer etwas kleinere jetzt habe ich hier
noch mal den verband ausgerollt 5 mm 3
oder weg besser gesagt mit diesen
hölzern und schneidet als kleine
rechtecke so und das wird oben dann
nochmal der abschluss
und die werde ich jetzt hier oben noch
dran
die steine sind jetzt soweit fertig
jetzt habe ich hier etwas braune locken
passte als sicher weiße blüte einfach
frauen eingefärbt und habe es bereits
ausgerollt ein bisschen antrocknen
machen und daraus werde ich jetzt das
tor schneiden und zum beispiel auf seine
fans
und die werde jetzt gleich strukturiert
und dann noch befördert und zwar mit
braunen und schwarzen lebensmittel
farbpulver euch halt kein braunes pulver
und die deko für das tor welches mit
silbernem verkäufer bewundern
a
jetzt mache ich noch eine fackel hier
vorne dran und von dem der dafür rot und
gelb und vermischtes so ein bisschen das
so eine kleine marmorierte optik
entsteht und habe hier bereits kleine
schwarze teile vorbereitet in die unten
spitz geformt mit dem tier immer ein
bisschen von dem rot gelb gemisch und
formen das auch nach oben hin zu einer
spitzen sieht das aus wie so wieso feuer
a
die torte sind so gut wie fertig die
flak ist auch schön durchgetrocknet und
hängt auch hier stabil auf dem spiel
und jetzt werde ich mit der restlichen
butter themen noch das skateboard
bisschen einstreichen
und hier habe ich ein paar kekse da habe
ich durch ihn heraus also die füllung
und hab sie zerbröselt und dass wir dann
einfach ein bisschen die erde und die
kommt sowohl auf die platte als auch
hier ihren reihen
und diese kuchen rettet dich noch habe
werde ich jetzt hier vorne ein bisschen
einkleben und zwar sieht es dann aus
hügelige landschaft
die steine darfst jetzt hier draufkleben
okay
a
zum schluss kommt die fahnen
unsere tochter ist jetzt fertig und sie
ist auch noch mal gut gekühlt und samira
darf es probieren
heute haben wir einfach eine reine
mädels torte gemacht wir zwei ganz ohne
papa
gib mir deinen teil auf
wenn wir beide mal probieren
wäre es ein richtig leckeres saftiger
schokolade
und
danke für deine also uns schmeckt der
kuchen sehr gut vor allem ist da
wirklich vom aufbau her sehr einfach
keine von landeck drüber sondern einfach
nur einzelne elemente
das heißt ihr könnt den kuchen seeburg
auch ganz einfach mit kindern gestalten
jetzt kommen wir noch zum gewinnspiel
und zwar gibt es zu gewinnen 3 x 2
kinotickets für den film burg
schreckenstein und zwar dürfte folgende
frage beantworten wie heißt das internat
der mädels also dass der jungs ist ja
burg schreckenstein und das der mädels
das dürfte mir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
auf facebook in friedberg oder auch
youtube und wir werden die gewinner dann
ermitteln und ihr werdet schriftlich
benachrichtigt unfall sie jetzt auch
musste bekommen habt oft diese torte
dann geht auch sallys - lockte jeder
stets noch mal ganz genau ich finde
diese burg ist auch eine ganz tolle idee
zum beispiel mal als geburtstagstorte
mag eine richtig coole mädels burg draus
machen oder so eine prinzessinnen burg
können wir auch mal machen und falls ihr
die torte nach halloween burg passt auch
ganz gut
und falls ihr die torte man nach macht
dann schickt uns auf jeden fall ein foto
auf facebook app instagram also viel
spaß bis zum nächsten mal